I love going back and reading like early  career roles for people and one thing I  was reading about you is that you were  like the girl screaming at Jason Segel  and I love you oh my god I was so green  on that job that I when the director  said camera I started I didn't know to  wait for action so there was that  because I was supposed to be running so  I just took off running like wait we're  not started yet you to come back here  and I remember that Jason Segel was just  so lovely and so nice and I was so I  remember just being very nervous it was  I had just moved out to LA and it was  one of my very first jobs and he  couldn't have been nicer